I was asked the other day by an
entrepreneur on how to stay focused and
why is it so hard to be focused and you
know I started talking to him to see
what he meant by how hard it is to stay
focus as an entrepreneur and I told him
I said you know I completely seen in a
different way says what is that I said I
think it's extremely hard to be
distracted I think it's very easy to be
focused I think life is very difficult
and stressful when you're distracted
it's very easy and happy and stress-free
a lot less when your focus is what I
mean by that's it
so he's a younger guy so when you're
talking to somebody who's younger he
stone the party life all this other
stuff I said let me ask you a question
you ever dated multiple girls at the
same time and he says what do you mean I
said have you ever had three girlfriends
and he's got the smirk on his face you
know he's a good-looking guy so he said
I have I said have you accidently text
the wrong name to the wrong number he
starts laughing I said of course I have
I said what was the reaction would you
have to say was my cousin what did you
have to do and he goes into his old
story I said I said how hard is it to
try to balance three different
relationships at the same time he says
Pat it's so stressful man the other day
I went to the mall and have to be
careful because my other girlfriend's
friend saw me and with this other girl
she wanted a whole dance and I didn't I
didn't how to separate mine all this up
he's telling me I said okay
I said so that to me is being distracted
it's a lot easier having one girlfriend
having one girlfriend you don't have to
worry about any of that stuff you're
dealing would want now some people will
watch this and they'll say well you know
I prefer being a player in all this
other stuff but then don't expect to you
know if you take that mindset into
business don't expect to do big things
in business don't expect to do big
things in business you hear a lot of
people that say you know I'm a fan of
multiple streams of income yeah that was
written by an author who made money
convincing you that the right thing to
do is multiple streams of income but I
was one more cuban last week and well
these guys are not they didn't make
their money going and having multiple
streams of income while he's in shark
tank he invests a lot of different bits
on he's worth three billion dollars now
but inna may didn't get there doing five
six seven
and things he went through micro
solutions home one big kid next phone
number broadcast boom next and then
comes other opportunities and even if
you look at Mark Cuban generally Mark
Cuban is an active owner with Dallas
Mavericks he doesn't just go to one game
and it never shows up again he's an
active owner he's actively involved with
his team with his business with with the
people that he's then I saw players on a
platform right and so less is more one
spouse one girlfriend one husband one
girl one boyfriend one partner one way
of making money Andrew Carnegie said I
don't believe in you know not putting
all of your eggs in one basket I believe
them putting all your eggs in one basket
just making sure nobody throws them down
I believe all in would one industry and
a lot of people so I don't like to do it
like that because it's risky what if
this this dist is that what if what then
don't plan on building it very big if
you want to put your energy in different
places so I run a financial firm and I
get normally get ass and people would
tell me well why don't we also offer
this product why don't we also offer
this product and many times as a person
running a business you still get tempted
because you're thinking we should offer
that product but I would come back and
say I would rather take Bruce Lee's
philosophy Bruce Lee said I'm more
concerned about fighting one person who
has practiced one kick 10,000 times
versus finding a person that's practiced
hundred different kicks a hundred times
if you come in practice you know a
person that's practiced one move ten
thousand times he can knock you out with
that one move the other person is going
to look at what all the different things
is doing but this guy knows this one
kick he hits you you're gone
Ron DeRussy style you're gone if you get
caught with this kick so minimize
everything try to minimize the
distractions if you have 20 friends men
bring it down to two three four friends
if you're if you're reading seven
different subjects bring it down to one
two different subjects you don't need to
read romance novel and read this and
read that and read this and read that
and read this read business if you're in
real estate just read real estate you
know in sales if you're in financial
services financial services and
those people if you're but limit your
stuff on what you're studying okay if
it's extremely close cousins only hang
out with two or three cousins you can't
do it with 50 75 different cousins
minimize it there's a lot of people that
like to answer everybody's calls with
their problems and everyone has the
friend that calls on hell you won't
believe what's going on with me and
Maryanne you won't believe what's going
on with me and Jacqueline you don't
believe what's going on with me and Bob
and you won't believe what's going on
there are people that enjoy everyone
calling them with their problems but I
tell you what don't expect to win in
life don't expect to win in life if you
want everybody to call you all the time
with all their problems and you're on
the phone with them for one hour if you
try to save the world you're probably
not going to be doing too big in
business because all you're concerned
about is trying to solve everybody's
problems minimize social media we got a
million in one apps nowadays let me do
this let me keep up with that let me
keep up with this let me keep up with
that let me keep up with that minimize
to one or two apps I did a video on this
you know how to stand out on social
media and I was very specific on how to
minimize and be very detailed on how you
do certain things to have the time for
yourself but in any aspect of your life
first you got to understand that being
focused is a lot more easier and happier
life if your focus over being distracted
then write out your plan in your life
your business what do you sell do you
focus on selling 50 products I focus on
selling three products in financial
services we have more my focus is three
do you focus on three you know Gary
Keller or the CEO of Keller Williams
which very impressed with him on what
he's done I really respect them as a CEO
everywhere I go when I see Gary Keller
when I see Keller Williams convention I
always tell them I said you know your
CEO is a very special CEO and they said
well you know you don't know Gary Keller
when Gary Keller is on meeting sometimes
it's very hard on this I said it doesn't
mean a very special CEO is not going to
be hard on you they said well you know
it's not that it's just very tough on us
sometimes and thought that that said
look Gary Keller wrote a book called the
one thing okay where he says after 20
years of being in a business I finally
realized instead of trying to do 50
different things had to do the one thing
and everything in his life became about
what's the one thing to do and it's
simplified his life and it took his
business from what it was to billions of
dollars because he focused on one thing
I see so many times amateur
entrepreneurs see somebody doing very
well in real estate they want to do real
estate
somebody doing very well in in in a
whole different business I'm going
technology I'm going to go into this I'm
gonna go into that I got involved in one
of the most people will say one of the
most boring industries in the world
insurance do you know what insurance
people tell me that's a boring industry
I fell in love with it call me crazy if
you want and my friends try to get me to
all these other businesses I've been in
the same business since the day before
9/11 insurance some financial industry
and I went from trauma sell every
product have a serious 760 631 I can
sell futures commodities all this stuff
I've had the license for throughout my
career it just kept getting like this
tighter into fewer products while I saw
a lot of my friends going like this you
go like this too many things to become
an expert in you go like this it's a lot
easier to become an expert in so when
you watch this video I'd love to hear
your questions when you watch this video
my challenge to you instead of trying to
do everything instead of trying to be
everything to everybody
minimize your focus in every aspect of
your life to fewer things and you will
be amazed how much better you're going
to be with those those three friends
your relationship will be so much more
fruitful than those 42 friends your
business career selling fewer products
will be so much more better than you
trying to sell everything to everybody
you'll do so much better than that then
trying to do everything to everybody
anyways that's my message to you here
when people ask how do I stay focused
that's my message to you minimize things
focus your attention on that and you'll
notice you'll do a lot better perform a
lot better and be a lot happier with the
results it's my message of the week to
you please be sure to comment on the
bottom and subscribe to the channel
thanks for watching
you